sur cette devantures de boutiques le mot
ouvert écrit en russe nous sommes à cram
à tort ce que dans l'est de l'ukraine où
la vie tente de reprendre peu à peu
malgré la guerre
notre rue est très grande avec beaucoup
de maisons probablement 300 les
habitants étaient presque tous partis
aujourd'hui ils sont quasiment tous
revenus
ici les rues ont l'air étrangement calme
les problèmes semblent plutôt liées au
pouvoir d'achat comme l'expliquent en
russe ce réparateur de vélos
j'ai une chaîne youtube et beaucoup de
mes abonnés m'ont demandé quand nous
allions couvrir car leurs vélos avaient
besoin d'être réparé
le prix de l'essence a beaucoup augmenté
alors plein de gens prennent leur vélo
cramatte or ce n'est pourtant qu'à
quelques kilomètres de la ligne de front
pour comprendre voici la région du
donbass de grandes provinces la
composent celle de louhansk et de
donetsk après la chute de l'iscid shank
les russes contrôlent désormais la
totalité de louhansk et une grande
partie de donetsk en jaune voici la zone
du donbass encore sous pavillon
ukrainien cramatte or ce qu en fait
partie mais pour combien de temps
dimanche dernier la ville a été à son
tour frappé par des roquettes russe tout
comme la commune voisine de ce lot
viande qu cramatte or ce qu est le
centre administratif du donbass si elle
tombe c'est toute la région qui serait
clairement menacé